Boa noite a todos é um grande prazer
fazer mais uma live com essa dupla de
férias aqui os grandes especialistas
referências na kinesiologia médica o Dr
Fausto bos que é o presidente da
sociedade italiana de kinesiologia
médica e
Odontológica ele utiliza uma abordagem
holística que integra fatores físicos
emocionais nutricionais e
ambientais e é conhecido pelo seu
trabalho em diversas áreas de saúde
incluindo dor músculo esquelética
problemas digestivos e a sua prática
terapêutica é amplamente reconhecida
pela precisão diagnóstico e tratamentos
que Ele oferece e conjuntamente com Dr
Fausto nós temos a Dra Cláudia Silveira
especialista em terapia neural e também
uma referência e kinesiologia médica no
Brasil Então temos aqui duas grandes
feras nesse tema e o objetivo da nossa
Live hoje é justamente entender como que
a kinesiologia pode ajudar o
profissional de saúde médico dentista o
o terapeuta que tem essa visão mais
integrada da saúde a priorizar o que que
ele vai tratar primeiramente porque nós
temos com frequência esse desafio de
pessoas que têm múltiplas doenças ou
múltiplos problemas de saúde e às vezes
é bem difícil entender como priorizar o
que abordar inicialmente então eu
agradeço a presença dos dois
eh e Convido os dois a se apresentarem
já é a segunda Live que eles estão aqui
conosco mas então eu gostaria que vocês
dessem um alô pro nosso público D
Cláudio Dr Fausto primeiro você Cláudia
mulher mulher sempre as as damas
primeiro né d f é as damas primeiro sim
aqui na Itália o sempre para frente sim
com certeza boa noite alaim boa noite Dr
Fausto Bosque diretamente aí da Itália
Boa noite a todos vocês que estão
assistindo a Live que vão assistir
depois
eh eu gostaria de agradecer a aí o seu
convite porque eh somos apaixonados eh
por entender o nosso paciente e
particularmente eu percebo em você um um
grande dom de se preocupar com o que
está acontecendo verdadeiramente com o
paciente e o que você pode oferecer de
melhor para esse paciente então
eh eu sou mestre né em terapia neural e
aprendi a potencializar a terapia neural
a partir da kinesiologia médica que
também me faz potencializar todas as
minhas ferramentas que eu tenho de
tratamento e fazer um guia para esse
tratamento super personalizado para os
pacientes um prazer estar aqui vamos
fazer uma linda Live você também alim
que está entrando pro nosso grupo da
kinesiologia médica em breve também um
expert em kinesiologia médica e Terapia
neural é seja bem-vindo viu Obrigada
Obrigado
é boa noite para
todos eu sou o Professor Fausto Bosque
estou aqui na Itália em ruma aqui éem
madrugada em madrugada vai eu estou
acostumado de nunc dormire
perch Bras posso
dormire som in Odontologia kinesiologia
Medica kinesiologia odontologica
kinesiologia
applicata poia o Che fac [ __ ]
ferramenta cosas perché una ferramenta
molto molto
poderosa problem
diagnos
diagn
biologia equilib
gro la chia
magica Italia un tempo
che no
una e
de sol poas
palavras che una ferramenta che no attu
solendo Test muscolos Test muscol teste
muscol esiste esiste un idioma CPO che o
o ida muscular o grupo fala com o tesse
muscular responda à nossas perguntas nós
vamos fazer ao grupo de paciente
respondas com por meio do do 10 muscular
agora isso é só para presentar a
ferramenta mas na verdade isso é muito
mais e
mais da ajuda muito mais muito mais mais
profunda me desculpo é eu falo português
mas tenho buos
muito bem você Você é médico Você é
médico é especialista em
odontoestomatologia né fals e por isso
você trabalha no corpo mas conhece a
boca trabalha eu sou eu tenho as duas As
duas como se chama qualas graduações
graduações
séo e odo as
duas posso come
comeo ISO M Fantastico perché posso un
pazen completo completo che completo
cheal ital ho
assunto razion
involv
1985 86 8 non lro
Ben Italia che odontologo perché
foii no primeros no
primer profession
che interessa ferramenta
perché o pod dessa ferramenta
eora eu tenho 40 an esperienza ah 40 me
V an
esperienza materia ferramenta
e lro quant casos ten tratamento
m verol
[Música]
comeo no in 40
Anni
non esiste un gruppo esiste una società
Italia soci antica do Mondo che studia
kinesiologia magica e no stamo su gruppo
di pesch
pisadores presiden Della società e no
sempre a com' Claudia a diantar no aant
aant
é s parpar
o o que nós vamos o que nós vamos
descobrir é sou feliz de poder de poder
falar que a d Cláudia Nossa pesquisadora
aqui da Itália ela não fala isso mas a d
Cláudia é uma das nossas melhores eh
como é pesquisadora pesquisadora
pesquisadora Deia aqui na
Itala umer que ela é é Nossa Socia da
sociedade umer verdade hum
gratidão também também ela é minha
professora nos nossos cursos ela ela é
minha
professora
também
obrig maravilha
então neologia M como ferramenta adota
uma abordagem holística né com certeza
os os dois especialistas que nós estamos
entrevistando hoje vocês podem dar a as
suas opiniões como é que vocês
consideram os aspectos emocionais
nutricionais e ambientais na avaliação
dos pacientes e também no tratamento
deles Cláudia obgado a você
eh como nós podemos
eh oferecer o nosso serviço ao paciente
é isso Você perguntou lin é eh como é
que você aborda eh como é que a
kinesiologia considera os aspectos
emocionais nutricionais e ambientais
você pode explicar eh as ferramentas
dentro da
kinesiologia para distinguir esses
aspectos aí certo eh na maioria das
vezes o paciente chega aos consultórios
né com aflição até L eu penso que até
para o paciente hoje decidir quando tem
um problema quando tem um sintoma a que
profissional ele vai recorrer a que
profissional ele vai é difícil porque
com as super
especialidades cada médico conhece de
uma parte aí você vai no gastro se você
tem um problema de estômago aí vai no
cardiologista se tem um problema se
sente um uma dor no coração que você nem
sabe se é mesmo no coração o paciente
acaba tendo que procurar o diagnóstico
de onde é o problema que ele está
sentindo para procurar o especialista e
quando chega no especialista
o paciente ainda tem que fazer vários
exames gastar muito dinheiro muitas
vezes não tem o plano de saúde e muitas
vezes o plano de saúde não aprova
aqueles todos aqueles exames e com a
super
especialidade muitas vezes o
cardiologista não entende muito bem por
exemplo do pâncreas aí o endócrino não
entende muito bem da postura então a
especialização faz com que um médico não
consiga ver o paciente como um todo
então o paciente tem que cuidar do
pulmão com
pneumologista cuidado do fígado com um
hepatologista E por aí vai se
fragmentando o serão um dentista cuida
da boca é como se o ser humano fosse
pedaços como se o paciente nosso
paciente fosse pedaços e cada pedaço uma
pessoa cuida com a kinesiologia médica
nós
podemos
analisar realizar um diagnóstico do
paciente como um todo por qu porque
quando um paciente muitas vezes ele tem
um problema vamos colocar assim de
estômago ele também pode ter um
Problema Emocional do do âmbito psiquê
pode ter um problema do ambiente onde
ele mora que são problemas
toxicação de de intolerância e Enfim
pode ter vários outros problemas e com a
kinesiologia médica nós vamos avaliar em
que esfera o paciente tem problema do
estrutural ao psiquê passando
pelo
pelo pela geopatia até avaliando o
crânio do
paciente analisando a química do
paciente a todos os fatores que podem
causar transtorno a esse paciente
inclusive avaliar se ele tem um problema
na
válvula
hum tivemos um probleminha aí no áudio
da Doutora Cláudia não El ele apou é a
internet dela deu uma congelada como
tinha acontecido antes bem D Fausto o
Senor pode continuar o raciocí sim poss
posso posso posso continuar voltei
voltou
E aí com a kinesiologia médica nós vamos
fazer uma consulta completa do paciente
identificando em ques áreas ele tem
problema e vamos conseguir fazer com uma
eh tipo hierarquização vamos conseguir
descobrir a necessidade do tratamento
por exemplo se esse um paciente tem
vários sintomas e tem um problema em
várias áreas como psq o bioquímico o
estrutural vamos conseguir eh
identificar por onde vamos começar o
tratamento ol isso é muito importante eu
creio que você se depare com muitos
pacientes assim né que tem sim vários
problemas e aí a gente consegue através
da kinesiologia médica identificar por
onde aquele paciente precisa ser tratado
por onde inicia que é justamente a
necessidade primordial dele depois o que
precisa segundo o que precisa em
terceiro e também vamos poder
Identificar qual é o melhor tratamento
que nós temos para aquele paciente nós
vamos também poder
eh analisar em relação a um fármaco por
exemplo a eh a concentração a quantidade
de quantas em quantas horas enfim vamos
fazer um tratamento assim um diagnóstico
muito apurado e bastante holístico do
paciente entendeu então para quem tá
tendo contato primeira vez com o
conceito da kinesiologia médica eu vou
falar assim de uma maneira muito simples
e incompleta dentro do meu
entendimento porque assim eu eu vou dar
aquela visão para iniciantes que aí
vocês como especialistas vocês vão
complementar o que eu tô dizendo então
para quem não conhece nunca ouviu falar
são testes musculares que você faz é
como se fosse um exame físico que você
testa vários músculos do corpo esses
testes vão dar pista se o problema é
bioquímico se o problema é estrutural se
o problema tá ligado à cicatriz se o
problema tá ligado a problema da boca e
por aí vai então é uma maneira muito
interessante de você hierarquizar o que
que quer dizer isso então você às vezes
tem um paciente que tem 10 sintomas e 20
sinais no exame físico você vai saber
por exemplo como é que eu começo eu
começo pela queixa gastrointestinal eu
começo pela
queixa de fog de Neva mental eu começo
pelo problema que esse paciente tá me
queixando como queixa principal eu
começo pela quinta queixa que de repente
ele pensa que é a menos importante mas é
a principal que deveria começar Então é
isso que nós estamos discutindo aqui
então é como se fosse um exame físico só
que existe toda uma
sequência para você poder entender
através desses testes musculares qual
que são os problemas principais e também
através
da sofisticação dos Testes vai conseguir
Identificar qual é a origem principal do
problema então eu tô dando essa
introdução bem fácil assim bem for
dam a partir daí os nossos especialistas
poderem desenvolver o tema falei
besteira D Cláudia não falou bem
maravilhosamente bem só falta assim tá
Fantástico e você também hoje já já vai
se tornando um Expert porque está
conosco você faz parte do nosso grupo né
da kinesiologia médica no Brasil olha Eh
Só faltou você falar da questão da
postura né A kinesiologia médica eh não
é igual a kinesiologia aplicada não é
aquela kinesiologia que fazem os
fisioterapeutas na kinesiologia aplicada
é uma kinesiologia diferente é tipo um
se eu também estiver falando um pouco
difícil do entendimento você me fala ou
então você completa a kinesiologia
médica é uma proposta de consulta tipo é
um um protocolo de consulta onde você
vai iniciar avaliando a postura do
paciente a partir de fotos né de vários
ângulos porque postura significa boa boa
postura significa saúde e qualquer tipo
de desvio de postura significa que esse
paciente tem um problema seja a nível de
olho seja a nível de boca seja a nível
de de pelv né em qualquer área do corpo
pé qualquer problema eles ele tem
relacionado à postura então boa postura
saúde uma postura doença então nós
fazemos primeiro primeiro lugar
avaliação da postura com fotos
registramos ali e partimos para o exame
físico Onde vamos avaliar como você
falou vários m músculos nós vamos
avaliar cada cada setor do corpo através
da tonicidade muscular
eh e o mais uma das coisas fantásticas é
que cada mús cada músculo corresponde a
um dente né Nós temos um dente
correspondendo a cada músculo que se
liga
neurologicamente e nós vamos fazendo
essa correlação com a boca com a
oclusão com todos os aspectos que
envolvem o ser humano é super completa
como você viu né ela em São Paulo é
super completa e fidedigna porque quando
vamos avaliando né como traçamos esse
diálogo com a parte do com o tecido
muscular do paciente com a parte
muscular eh o paciente vai entendendo e
vai percebendo que nós estamos acessando
o inconsciente dele né através da
linguagem muscular eh a kinesiologia
médica né ela faz uma leitura através de
um idioma de perguntas sim não então na
terapia neural por exemplo os terapeutas
neurais Precisam fazer assim como os
todos os médicos né precisam de uma
annese profunda e apurada e vai depender
da nossa
interpretação da vontade do paciente de
falar a verdade já com a kinesiologia
médica nós temos a facilidade de acessar
aquilo que o
paciente não sabe falar
Lógico que nós vamos pedir o
consentimento mas nós acessamos
informações que muitas vezes ele nem
lembrava mais Então é assim nós vamos
fazer o médico tem uma vai ter uma
consulta o médico o cirurgião dentista o
profissional do diagnóstico tem um
modelo de consulta onde ele vai fazendo
a guia e vai anotando todos os dados e
no final da consulta se traça um
diagnóstico e esse diagnóstico vai ele
vai aprofundando como se tivesse é
fatiando o paciente tipo assim camadas
ou comumente falando tipo um cebola
primeira parte segunda parte terceira
parte até chegar no centro do problema
então muitas vezes nós fazemos algumas
consultas no paciente e vamos resolvendo
esses problemas do mais grave que o mais
grave significa o que ele necessita
tratar naquele momento ao que ele quer
tratar por último falei dá para entender
dend
simo come doore stava fando o
noooooo inves
buica
suo trattamento
todos os problemas na hierarquização
certa por quê temem ordem na
hierarquização na ordem certa é na ordem
S na ordem certa por que isso porque eh
na nossa experiência eh nós vemos que se
vamos tratar os problemas como é écho é
o acho
meou difil para m
e
e encontar sucesso parae pente eu
preciso pergun P
pergun não é pergunta ver pergunta
kinesiologia
qu Vamos
colocar qual vamos perguntar oente qual
a melor ordem
TR subconsciente no caso S per
[Música]
perché a
resposta
kinesiologica una resposta
verd che
respond pergunta
perguntas con muscolare risponde con
muscolare
a Forza musc muscolo forte
frag una
ind una
situ
DIP sto facendo
un mico che faleo ISO s faleo s sempre
ISO no ST sempre
AAS
perguntas perché o corpo responde sempre
sempre
inci che
mand
semprea sa preguntas compo prend
nost ins cos come pergun che pergunt
perché important che perun pergun emo
Con certeza chimico con certezza
intossicazione con certezza la
situazione
strutturato M important
paz la situazione
come vive no amb
vive Son
che
elettromagnetica
elettromagnetica a in Roma a Roma no
stamo su un problema gravis polluzione
elettromagnetica e io sto buscando
sempre Ma spazen Che temp pollion
elettromagnetica una grande sag no
sape
temos
cellular TV
Radio possio no e io sto buscando sempre
maaz buscando incontr
incando sto a
busc e sto incontr sempre ma spaz
problema
di elettromagnetica incredibile SAP che
un tempo Noni non er
sorao un
esemp esemp io posso diagnosticare
cipo auriem se cellular se non
sei qualche appiglio qualche appiglio
elettronico o comput TV Ma
Che ord ordinare Claudio S ordinare
nonto certo perché che sempre fa scos ho
SC
vamos a cebola zeola zeola zeola zeola
cipolla in italiano cipolla scassa
perché perché c
c o problema pi
interior AD buscare esterior
important intend come si
chiama percorso Claudia percorso
percorso da duen no percorso duza MA
important
interior da ceola ISO che che
investigare
e buscare incontrare tratare
isoo m
importante
iiz
iiz falando é ver não é per
RSO
cursos
e
c se com' incos Claudio no Bras eh no
Bras Nostra la Nostra formazione Bras un
Corso basico un Corso avanzato e dose
incontr do
incontr online una for
m m dura M
dura
prof poemos D una
ferramenta come si fa una ferramenta
paro o tot o
nadao per
magica traidora traidora significa che o
con ben ben magica
oens magica sol Un Poco cono
impossibile Con certeza porque não
podemos fazer diagnóstico certo essente
se não sabemos tudo se não conocemos
todos os tes não conocemos conocemos non
conocemos eh todas
a as procuras n de pesquisa [ __ ]
formação é
muito é muito longa longe longe muit
long longa M longa
é é assesso é é impossí
assio un
desafio un par un desafio eo fallo
sempre a ch a Roma e Bras sto parlando
MMO
io com' rovinare Claudio rovinare destru
destrui e io C destru la sua
Vita oggi futuro non consi mai
bagli come
traglia un tempo ora che sape ento non
cos perché Sta sempre pensando oh che
sto facendo oh certo Oh sto errando non
sei che che
non
Vita tempo F tempo da
F sen
si B benv
C pass tut tut Chei posso
passare un
des bonito profession bonito des
apprendimento
bonito bonito
claudiao lind n muito
lind então na experiência dos dois quais
são as condições de saúde que são mais
frequentes mais
Daia
exis problemas ou condições são mais
comuns
e quais são essas condições que vocês
vem que kinesiologia se destaca em
relação à Medicina Ortodoxa de repente
que os exames habituais não chegam a
mesma conclusão que a as ferramentas
da
entendi eu trabalho muito aor cronica
muito quor cronica temamos pente
che Sta con
cronica an an in e Che Non risolo non
risolo non risolo
perché chea dott no Prof Prof consi ver
oesse no un problema un problema
vend Avis globale olistica is la
differenza fondamentale kinesiologia
magica olistica
allin po immaginare che per
esempio un problema un problema solo un
esempio eh un esempio del Nostro
contimento un problema de artrosis do
cotovelo
cotovelo coto devido a parasitas
intestinais
in ISO perch incrivel ISO normal perché
existe una
ativa sistema come si chama immunologic
immunitario Claudia immunologic
immunologic per la culpa parasitas
sistema immunologica ci Vado vai deposit
complexos articol e come si chama
complexos antigeni anticorpus come
chiama portugese simo MMO antigo
anticorpo antigo anticorpo articola
artosis artosis por
porque imunologico al aí
ent fica acado noeto pior culpa dos
paritas por
exemp esemplo eh iso é o que manca
medicina tradional e Avis
globis fal o que manca o que falta o que
falta
até dentro dos estudos né é mais
recentes de fisiologia intestinal é que
vários agentes intestinais parasitas
fungos seguro bactérias podem provocar o
liqu gate que é o intestino que vasa
hiper permeável
isso pode causar imunocomplexos no na
placa de paia do intestino esse
imunocomplexos viajam e pode atingir a
tireoide a
articulação qualquer lugar isso isso é
verdade é isso é só um exemplo alí né s
un esemplo per
intend
intend assunto de Pens
glob una paravra paravra lacina olos
olos idom lacina
significa tudo no tudo
Global Nostro assunto un assunto
olistico olistica italiano non sai in
portugese
come come la parra asma
olis Nostro intendimento
da un intendimento olistico perché
perché da qualche causa perché non come
Bene perché un
problema paré un problema
valv stir Claudia
una
quan come
chiono
caus
in
incontr o percorso
patogeno causa da causa da causa da C
perché problema inizi problema problema
problema a te og a te
og sai conteni
cont con clas adesso un
tempo un tempo long longo long io sto
trattando
pazol su Nostro metodo Nostro di
trattamento
descob che assoar chinesi
magica una ferramenta
Poderosa
Poderosa come AC non esiste una
ferramenta benosa
noo un diagnostico di kinesiologia
trattamento
di neural terapia terapia neur Disculpa
neur kinesio con
kinesiologica imagina
immagino Italia
tamb
Italia o mundo chama de
[Música]
brusa
também né problemas do do crânio que no
Brasil não temos esse Esse costume de
avaliar o crânio das crianças os
problemas eh de locomoção os problemas
posturais relacionar o crânio e
conseguir na maioria das vezes reverter
esse problema né eu vejo isso também
muito impactante entendeu al sim sim é
verdade problemas de crânio
eh problemas também
problemas por exemplo pacientes com
disfunção da articulação temporo
mandibular né que são pacientes que têm
dor crônica pacientes que estão também
com diagnóstico de fibromialgia que
atendemos muitos que já foram submetidos
a cirurgia até da região cervical por
suspeitas de de lesão de hérnia e que o
profissional por achar que o problema é
na cervical faz a cirurgia realiza a
cirurgia também na TM e o problema de
origem está no pé por exemplo está no
quadril está na língua e faz a se
realiza a cirurgia e o problema continua
a dor aumenta enfim eh nós nós nós
atendemos muitos pacientes eh que T
problemas tem diagnóstico de
fibromialgia e na realidade tem um
desequilíbrio postural né E quando
resolvemos o postural reequilibram o
paciente
a as dores vão embora né É muito
perfeito e existe também uma aplicação
da kinesiologia médica pro desempenho
esportivo não é isso sim com certeza Dr
Fausto tem experiência né com essa
prática muita é muita muita tem muita é
o senhor pode falar um pouco como o
senhor utiliza essa prática da
kinesiologia para ajudar os atletas a
melhorar o desempenho e prevenir
ma sa cont verd
fesmo consult per un atleta a consulta
mesma para Una un advogato para Unico
para chama Casa Claudia
do
do do a
mesma verdade buscar o Che Non não
funziona B parae pente porque não
sabemos que primero temos que tiar as
causas vamos buscar as causas Vamos
hierarquizar colocar Nord
ceros Nord ceras causas vamos tirar as
causas exatamente e depois que vamos
tirar as causas vamos tratar o que nós
vamos encontrar não não existe um
trattamento
Desportivo tratamento
avar
muscolo sa se
difetto switching si Pero come si chiama
registro camio che un registro un
cadastro che Sta
qui si
Pero coord muscol perché possib ES siama
ciclista ciclista o
ciclista o c cam perché non cammina Sta
sempre come si chiama bicicletta no
bicicletta Sta sempre una bicicletta Ed
un
Desportivo
io
fci
figen dott
dott D un gito per che io fa quando fao
una come si chiama incontro di fucci
Ball no con meim di fucci Ball eo
preciso no correr non correr ma fa una
come si chiama un eh
cerada Uno scatto P di velocità e picco
di velocità io mi sisto quando Io
sono come siama campo campo de fucci
Ball non important io important io fao
prego b
e fug
B
All a macchina a macchina muscolare
perfetta equilibrio
servili
esemp un
problema
non che problema intestino che problema
di duen da valv non
consegi Claudia com' C
bola non cons a
BG
bna perché
perché muscolo
muscato Una
esempio possibile
cont frago frago non
consegi
bola isdo ma non omesmo
siele
isdo
non
esemp crianza
che come cesarea cesarea cesariana
seso cesareo che conteni te un cranio
con formaz cranio Un Poco differen no
perché non pass can parto non
Passi
falt compr esp che important
Pero cio
Cesario ania durme
desperta important che
esista come
[Música]
quandoo armonico
non Che Non ACC che accento
armonic rosto perio rosto di banana
rosto
de con Lar l d
no V
alter
eamo
tentare un po
come trando posizione den trocando
tragando con la posizione
arco queo e por esemplo inda o atlas D
crianza seas ve ST rota anterior no ST R
anterior vaiar
disturbio medulla spin e ISO Ecco causa
causa causa disturbio n Du pisas un
atleta
checi SP non consegi sare sol perché
sesia
Atlas
reorganiza
corp magica e Fas de Fas fando e fasio
de F perché un
diagnostico incont problema
problema Sta append come una
impossibilità ma non verd Tutto
possibile
só que precisa de um treinamento
treinamento e capacidade não como tudo
então eu queria perguntar para vocês
para os interessados Qual que é o
processo de formação e certificação para
se tornar um praticante da kinesiologia
médica vocês começaram a falar sobre
isso que tem a formação básica tem
avançada e tem a completa mas eu queria
que vocês falassem um pouco mais para
quem tá nos assistindo que tem interesse
Cláudia E e ter uma formação nisso
aí você certo para ter uma formação
assim
eh que possa realizar um bom trabalho o
profissional deve realizar primeiro uma
formação básica que é uma iniciação né
que constam são três dias depois uma
formação um pouco mais avançada onde o
profissional vai aprender a já realizar
uma consulta mais completa
com a
kinesiologia e daí partir para uma
formação
completa caso tenha interesse goste da
ferramenta que é difícil um profissional
não se
apaixonar porque à medida que você vai
conhecendo a kinesiologia médica você
vai entendendo que não é necessário
ansiedade para decidir o que precisa
fazer que que que que precisa realizar
no paciente e realizar terapêuticas
complexas então para adquirir esse
conhecimento existe a formação completa
que são 12 encontros presenciais em São
Paulo né
Eh em meses alternado porque um mês é
presencial outro mês é a mentoria online
onde o
profissional pode apresentar seus casos
clínicos pode atender um paciente
conosco e tem aquele encontro mesmo
muito particular porque as turmas T
poucos profissionais né Tem muita
prática enfim eh o nosso interesse é que
o profissional que esteja na formação
saia bastante capacitado para realizar
diagnósticos precisos e profundos eh Nós
não somos assim nós não temos interesse
em quantidade de profissionais nós
selecionamos o perfil do profissional
para que não seja banalizada a
kinesiologia médica né que temos muita
responsabilidade porque a questão é que
é uma ferramenta da propedêutica que o
profissional pode utilizá-la em qualquer
especialidade a qualquer momento
eh da sua consulta e precisa ser
realmente bem aprendida então é isso al
quem quiser aprender essa ferramenta
estamos estamos sempre à disposição
também nós formamos um grupo nós tiramos
perguntas e até depois da formação nós
temos a kinesiologia cibernética que é
uma kinesiologia especial que falaremos
depois em detalhes porque é muito
complexa enfim teremos uma turma agora
em junho né uma nova turma de formação
básica para quem quer mais detalhes
sobre como aderir essa formação
deixando aqui o contato no Instagram da
D Cláudia
Silveira porque dessa maneira você vai
ter todas as informações necessárias
Quando é que vai ter a próxima turma do
básico do intermediário do avançado
então ela poder passar todas as
informações para você que está
interessado eu queria fazer uma pergunta
D Cláudia também na opinião sua Quais
são os principais desafios que os
profissionais iniciantes enfrentando
começam a agregar a kinesiologia na sua
prática
eh eu acho que os um dos principais
desafio é compreender que uma
ferramenta tão Sutil e tão
eh profunda pode surtir um resultado
tão tão impactante porque no início
quando você pensa assim ah você vai
fazer testes e em músculos Ah isso não
vai funcionar Ah eu não vou conseguir
Mas não é verdade quando você vivencia
aquilo que você pratica que você toca
que você prova mesmo como diz o falso eh
os resultados eles são clínicos eles são
evidentes você vai se aprofundando se
encantando Quando você vai descobrindo o
novo mundo onde você vai realmente
utilizar tudo que é bom pro paciente
E aí você vai aprofundando e nunca mais
a kinesiologia médica sai da sua vida
então o maior desafio é acreditar e
provar e testar e incluir a kinesiologia
na sua vida né porque não precisa fazer
uma consulta exclusiva de kinesiologia
médica você pode utilizar na sua prática
normal como você trabalha seja
oftalmologista seja eh qualquer
especialidade você vai atuar ali dentro
da sua sua consulta como se fosse como
se fosse não é uma ferramenta um
instrumento na sua na sua propedêutica
né de propedêutica Então é isso o maior
desafio é acreditar é confiar e o outro
desafio é só alegria porque você se
torna autoridade eh no assunto paciente
o paciente percebe que Você o conhece o
paciente fica encantado geralmente um
paciente vai depois ele leva se for uma
uma uma mulher leva o marido leva os
filhos e vai assim de a família inteira
porque o efeito é
impactante da sua autoridade eh em
relação ao conhecimento ao paciente que
hoje isso é raro né E quando você com
relação a que você falou dos
atletas Acho que pelo idioma talvez
falso não tenho conseguido sintetizar
mas é muito importante a kinesiologia
médica para os atletas porque nós
podemos testar não testar todos os
músculos e muitas vezes e muitas vezes
um jogador de futebol um atleta Seja lá
de qualquer ordem do atletismo eh ele
tem uma dificuldade e o profissional que
vai tratar essa dificuldade geralmente
trata naquele local e o o problema está
sempre à distância kinesiologia médica
vai fazer Vai religar todos os músculos
Por exemplo quando um paciente tem um
problema a distância e o quadríceps não
funciona bem o jogador de futebol ao
invés de ficar mandando o jogador fazer
fortaleci ento muscular o o o
profissional fica tratando a parte
muscular o local do problema nós vamos
lá diagnosticar e tratar a distância
tipo um problema do crânio tipo um
problema na oclusão dentária que são
muitos
muit é existe muita correlação entre por
exemplo o as unidades doos molares com o
quadríceps existe uma intrinsa ligação e
aí se você conseguir tentar tratar o
músculo do Atleta você não consegue mas
se você tratar o dente do Atleta você
religa o músculo é sobre isso então
assim é uma ferramenta potente de
diagnóstico e associada à quines à
terapia neural outras ferramentas que
você tem é
incrível Então eu queria que você também
falasse um pouco eh Doutora Cláudia
porque eu sei que em conversas que nós
tivemos
anteriormente você comentou que mudou
completamente a sua abordagem da terapia
neural a partir do momento que você
agregou a kinesiologia Então eu queria
que você nos dissesse como é que foi
essa transição como é que era antes de
você conhecer a kinesiologia como é que
era a terapia neural e como é que ela
mudou na sua prática através desse
enriquecimento com os aprendizados da
kinesiologia olha lin foi é justamente o
que me encantou que me me levou a
aprofundar esses estudos aí pela Europa
direto e hoje eu trabalho trabalho com o
Professor Fausto é que quando eu conheci
a terapia neural eu me encantei só que
eu me encantei e por ser por ser sempre
assim fazer parte de conselho de classe
de comissão de ética eu ficava muito
preocupada porque eu teria que dar
resultado ao meu paciente com muita
responsabilidade e eu percebi
que nós nós terapeutas neurais né
tradicionais nós vamos realizar um
procedimento maravilhoso eh incrível o
paciente de dor crônica naquele momento
melhora daquela dor e fica assim
Encantado mas nós logo depois nós não
temos um uma capacidade de
previsibilidade para esse paciente nós
podemos fazer um efeito instantes né que
o anestésico local em baixíssima
concentração faz esse esse fenômeno
produz esse fenômeno Mais logo depois o
paciente retornava D aí eu compreendi
com a kinesiologia médica que nós temos
que identificar se esse paciente tem um
problema estrutural se tem um problema
de bioquímica se tem uma intolerância
uma alergia uma intoxicação ou um
problema de geopatia ou um problema de
ordem que a terapia neural não faz
milagres então assim com a kinesiologia
médica eu entendi que eu posso
eh só realment a terapia neural quando o
paciente necessita Quando vai ser bom
para esse paciente quando eu vou ter
assim um resultado que eu possa confiar
mas também assim eu entendo que a
terapia neural não é não precisa ser
usada em determinada Instância do
paciente porque ela melhora a vida de um
paciente em qualquer estágio da doença
seja no Cuidado paliativo seja na
prevenção
eh quando você melhora o sistema
imunitário do paciente eu entendo mas o
que fortaleceu impactou a minha conduta
como terapeuta neural e hoje eu me sinto
muito segura É que eu só vou realizar a
terapia neural no paciente se ele
necessita porque muitas vezes o paciente
não necessita não é aquilo que ele
precisa naquele momento muitas vezes ele
tem uma alergia ao anestésico local a
concent a não é adequada e antes eu
usava a terapia neural com uma procaína
ou uma lidocaína sem vaso com a
concentração que o profissional
recomendava com o método dele por 2% 07
o 05 então assim como terapeuta neural
eu me sentia nas mãos da pessoa que
desenvolvia um
protocolo que dizia que era para usar em
todos e na realidade nós estamos estamos
com o paciente na mão que é único que
tem
particularidades isso me deixava
insegura com a kinesiologia médica eu
vou testando até a sequência dos pontos
que vou utilizar vou testando se o
paciente aceita naquele momento aquele
ponto enfim eu testo tudo não tenho
ansiedade e tenho resultados assim
incríveis né é
isso ótimo aproveitar aqui que depois
desseu relato Primeiro vou mostrar aqui
o comentário do João
Guerra o depoimento dele aqui sobre a
kinesiologia E também temos uma pergunta
aqui ah mas antes de responder a
pergunta ao vivo a Joseli tá perguntando
se vai ficar gravado
Joseli desde que eu comecei o canal no
YouTube tudo fica gravado Fica tranquilo
tá é uma novidade tem uns oito que fica
gravado mas só para te avisar fica
gravado Fica tranquila viu
Eh agora a pergunta aqui dá para Oler aí
Cláudia dá Doutora Cláudia pacientes
cons ela de AVC síndrome pópo e outras
comorbidades neurológicas T bons
resultados sim tem bons resultados eh
Porque a terapia neural né associada a
kinesiologia médica ela faz um estímulo
ao sistema nervoso central né e faz uma
promove uma autorregulação em relação à
kinesiologia médica para pacientes com
sequelas ela vai atuar num diagnóstico
preciso inclusive buscando a causa desse
AVC o que causou esse AVC e vai fazer
uma prevenção em um segundo nível para
que esse paciente não tenha um outro AVC
e não tenha uma outra complicação Então
vai
and o dano não sei se eu estou
conseguindo
eh falar numa linguagem acessível mas
por exemplo numa síndrome pós pólio eh
em comorbidades tanto neurológicas como
de outra ordem atua promovendo a
possibilidade de aumentar o ranger de
tolerância desse paciente a essas
comorbidades favorece com que
encontrando a real causa do paciente ter
adoecido nós vamos fortalecer esse
paciente né E vamos tratar também esses
sintomas eh de tudo que aconteceu com
ele através de
terapêuticas testadas eficazes e
melhorar sim eh a condição desse
paciente a encontrar o caminho da da da
sua autocura da sua do seu estímulo a
resistir a ter uma melhor condição de
fortalecer a capacidade de se regenerar
né ISO sei se eu
fale
consegi cludia você esu
deargia magica não é s
diagnostico diagnostico e cur també
prevenção sim prevenção também prevenção
podem encontrar
um problema muito tempo an que o
problema problema vai evidenciar e e
falar paziente che que olha você Isso
isso vamos salora vamos esperar que a
sua doença
fiab estab
estab nós vamos encontrar o problema
antes que isso se torne uma doença
muito tempo impedir que aquela doença se
manifeste no paciente
endeu exemplo
isico mico
faica
ferrosa diagnosticar
problema muito tempo an problema vai eh
S Cláudia
eh eh instado instalado instalado
instalado instalado muito tempo isso
isso é bom isso é bom para todos
obrigado Valdeci Obrigado qualquer
dúvida pode me chamar no meu Instagram
no Direct eh Então eu queria propor aqui
pra gente pros últimos minutos da Live a
gente apresentar aqui
eh da visão de vocês dois um caso de
cada um dos dois exemplo cas um caso
Clínico assim não precisa dar detalhes
assim mínimos detalhes mas aluma coisa
que ficou gravada na memória que ficou
impactada como a kinesiologia médica
ajudou pacientes específicos né que foi
fez toda a
diferença então Vocês poderiam cada um
de vocês falar um caso Clínico assim sem
muitas elaborações só paraa gente ter
uma ideia de como que a kinesiologia foi
Fundamental e que sem ela não teria
chegado ao ao âmago do problema
né
Eh Cláudia eu faleo você eu falou eu
mesmo pode cada um né eu vou falar eu
vou começar não estou estou lembrando de
uma moça uma moça JEM moça jovem de 25
anos que ficou com 15 anos de dor de dor
de cabea 15 anos ela foi tratada em
todos
centros
centrosa
Italia sen
sucesso consulta
diagnostico or
un
diagnostico di Campo elettromagnetico
non giretto ah
dott che Sta
fando tipoo
tipo non posso M quarto perché M Casa
pechina non sai dorm fac asseme
un tempo vai dorm una da sua una sua
amica
che da una C
dorm su mio
diza tomava
farmacos
farmac farmac for for for stava
zona getica ISO no dormia una TV
veo L Ah tava gerando uma energia
eletromagntica afetando saa isso S isso
era a causa cabe del isso causae del
porque porque SAP que a geop não um
sintoma specifico a geop se qual
sintoma reg geop e o problema fo un
centro di trattamento da capza Italia e
francia
spagna in Europa
tare
non
Claudia non risolo n non CONSEG non
risolve nada e Che un non sa come
unamica magico magico un logo tes
muscolos non sei nada non sei Nat che le
fai e f a Mia consulta a Mia consulta fa
lei
eete Uno stress un stress
elettromagnetico
graves Dev ver d gravis e fando fando
facendo testi che io posso diagnosticare
cibo del stress
elettromagnetico e la Pens che Fi a TV a
TV che stavan L Gir perto 1 metro
mando
casa testes se é uma energia
eletromagnética de um aparel ou se exemp
linha diagnostico
s feia é feia de verdade mas não é não é
o caso mais frequente de geop não é isso
aqui na Italia não agora agora está
sendo mais frequente por exemplo o
stress da polução electromagnética mais
da linha de ou do deé e dá para
diferenciar por exemplo se é um aparelho
específico ou se a pessoa tá numa região
por exemplo tem duas antenas de celular
próximo sim é possível sim sim é
possível possível diferenciar temos Test
opatia temos tudo né perfeito então é é
possível a Cláudia agora então vai
apresentar o seu caso aí também pra
gente ter esse exemplo o Dr Paulo já deu
esse exemplo que só conseguiu descobrir
a dor de cabeça por causa da
kinesiologia de outra forma ser
impossível e agora a Cláudia vai
apresentar pra gente uma coisa
semelhante aí você lembra de algum caso
clud sim muitos
eh depois da kinesiologia médica a minha
vida se transformou em pura a minha vida
Clínica se transformou em Pura Emoção eh
eu vou falar de um caso de uma paciente
que ela está assim que é um caso atual
né no qual ela me procurou né me
encontrou não por acaso porque na vida
não existe Coincidências
e me encontrou num salão e estava
falando sobre dor e ela falou que Sena
uma dores muito fortes e estava com
diagnóstico de fibromialgia e enfim
depois ela me procurou no Instagram e
ela me encontrou no Instagram e falou
preciso falar com você urgente até Ela
assistiu a nossa Live aaí pela nossa
Live ela me procurou depois e falou
Doutora Cláudia eu preciso falar com
você aí eu mandei ela entrar em contato
comigo pelo WhatsApp e nós marcamos
agendamos uma consulta nessa consulta
ela chegou desesperada ela e o marido e
com muita dor era uma dor no baixo
ventre ela terrível era como se tivesse
tudo ela disz que era como se tivesse
tudo desmontado dentro dela tinha muitos
anos já com essa dor
eh nem peças íntimas ela usava porque
ela não aguentava de tanta dor era uma
sensibilidade terrível
e já tinha percorrido psiquiatra que já
tinha passado vários psicotrópicos ela
não conseguiu mais usar
eh uroginecologista todo tipo que você
imaginar médico da dor ninguém resolvia
e chegaram a eh a falar para ela que ela
tava com problema psicológico e que a
dor dela era psicológica Enfim chegou em
Total desespero chegou na minha na minha
mesa de consulta se jogou e fez assim eu
vou ficar louca Acho que eu estou
ficando louca aí eu comecei a explicar o
que eu fazia né porque é algo estranho
eh no Brasil falar de kinesiologia
médica e o marido dela olhava para mim e
ficava escutando e ela também ficava
escutando então eu comecei a conversar e
falei da da do como era kinesiologia
médica ele até falou como ele é
engenheiro mecânico ele falou para mim
assim Ah agora eu confio porque
realmente quando tem essa interferência
esse nódulo de hartman quando eu coloco
uma máquina no nódulo de hartman não
funciona a máquina eu gostei dessa
abordagem pronto a ele sabia isso é ele
sabia isso sabia isso em relação à
máquinas em relação à máquina quando
quando coloc uma máquina no nó do de H
uma máquina não funciona verdade uhum aí
ele falou eu confio aí marcamos
agendamos a consulta e na consulta da
kinesiologia médica essa paciente
Apresentou um problema de cicatrizes um
problema eh de ordem mais que
psicológica psicológica não tinha nada
tinha uma algo no inconsciente dessa
paciente que estava guardado né fizemos
uma hierarquização e se na
hierarquização ficou definido o que a
prioridade seria uma cicatrizes né que
ela tinha um problema de cicatriz E aí
eu fui fiz todos os testes como era um
caso de emergência que essa
paciente nem dormia de tanta dor e já
também com problema psiquiátrico já de
dor eh eu resolvi fazer um teste para
saber se ela poderia tratar essa
cicatriz que era a primeira coisa que
ela pedia para ser tratada né no na na
kinesiologia se eu podia tratar com
terapia neural e aí disse que sim eu
tive um resultado que sim que deveria
tratar e eu fiz uma hierarquização das
cicatrizes eu fiz uma Fiz todo o nosso
protocolo diferenciado de terapia neural
e a primeira sessão de tratamento ala de
uma das cicatrizes a dor
sumiu essa paciente que tinha muitos
anos de dor ela deve estar escutando não
sei a Live ela vai escutar ela é assim
ela é uma apaixonada da da kinesiologia
médica e da terapia neural porque em uma
sessão a dor sumiu como como se fosse um
passe de mágica mas não é passe de
mágica né tem uma tem uma resposta eh
físicoquímica eh toda propriedade também
além do do tecido muscular com está
estão fazendo estudos hoje né nos
Estados Unidos da memória celular está
no tecido muscular da memória celular
Enfim então nessa nessa terapia neural
nessas cicatrizes a dor
desapareceu mas eu continuei tratando a
paciente que ela tinha várias ela
apresentava várias demandas e a cada
tratamento eh a paciente vem estando
melhor e o que mais me impactou é que um
uma das cicatrizes mais importantes foi
a cicatriz de um implante hormonal que
essa paciente tinha colocado colocou de
um lado deu um problema aí o
profissional passou pro outro lado só
que o que mais me impacta é que ela está
muito bem sem dor nenhuma mas essa
cicatriz do implante hormonal até hoje é
um problema muito grande na vida dela né
enfim assim eu estou tratando ela como
se fosse uma cebola a cada dia nós vamos
alcançando
eh uma qualidade melhor ela já indicou
as filhas e assim a kinesiologia médica
transforma transforma vidas em uma
sessão a dor foi embora ela não toma
nenhum fármaco e é isso mudou a vida das
filhas também Impact ótimo muito
interessante a a eu não desculpa eu não
sei se é mulher ou homem vanir Silva tá
perguntando se você tem alguma
experiência Claudia eí logicamente se
aplica o Dr Fausto com Alzheimer se
houve algum eh resultado de utilizar
cinesiologia médica com pacientes com
Alzheimer
temos temos muito temos
muitas inclusive para
saber tem relação com a com a com a
intoxicação de metais pesados nós temos
testadores de todos os metais pesados
enfim com a palavra ao Dr Fausto aí
sobre essa P nós temos que fazer um
diagnóstico
mais
Claudia
prce
Pri PR prossi ISO prossi maib prossi
verag sintoma M tempo
Sanchez cheza F involv con
sintoma pres
[Música]
la minia esperienza la minia esperienza
M important diagnostico intossicazione
come stava parlando la dottore
intossicazione met pesato intossicazione
paritas cus Alzheimer o Tutto che
inic potenzial po una ca di alzaimer Tut
che po intossicazione
que um metal
pesado alumin mesmo nome mesmo nome
mesmo nome alumínio e
do chumbo chumbo do Chumbo seo sa que
por aqui a
Roma no vos
pregos a condutta da
Aga de
chumbo ende isso aliás aliás dizem os
pesquisadores da história que o foi um
dos
principais elementos que acabou com o
império romano né porque todo
encanamento antiga era chumbo s a ainda
Roma incn debo o incad
incad come se
chador
travao
Inc Alzheimer
un caso non sei un
caso rispondere aa
pergunta diffo non esiste una causa Dal
una causa certa non esiste caus var
causa causa non
sufficiente
involvere una Z e sai una cosa non sai
chiato una
cosa emoziona
mais muito em voga hoje em dia dentro
dos estudos metabolômica é a questão dos
milhares e milhares de elementos
químicos a maioria deles derivados do
petróleo poluentes orgânicos
persistentes tá saindo uns estudos aí
mostrando que além
desses tóxicos ambientais tem daí um
fator mais complicador ainda que é os
microplásticos tá aparecendo já estudos
de presença de micro plásticos nas
paredes das artérias de coronária e
causando doença coronariana infarto quer
dizer acredito também que a kinesiologia
pode nos ajudar também com essas
intoxicações que não são metais pesados
mas que são derivados do petróleo e
plástico né não pode NSS ajuda para
fazer o
diagnóstico certeza o diagnostico tamb
trattamento
esemp falei queia
paz non sa
che mza mza in pazen
differen con
Du
Claudio protoco
tratt Claudia
con protocollo
protoco non che tratt
pazen
prisa trattato non posso TR un
pazen perché protocollo falla cheen si
tratta
s protocollo come siama
a morte da Medicina da Verdade a morte
sim sim sem dúvida tem que ser um
tratamento personalizado
personalizado individualizado né
interessante também no Alzheimer ver a
correlação da boca né porque muitos
pacientes T restaurações metálicas aumas
cheias de mercúrio implantes focos
dentários né focos dentários né
croses que muitas vezes o cirurgião
dentista não tem conhecimento né porque
não é uma culpa é da formação
profissional do Brasil é uma cultura não
avalia muito bem esses aspectos a
maioria dos cirurgiões dentistas né
ortodoxos não acreditam Acho que até é
loucura dos profissionais que AC eu
queria até fazer um relato aqui que eu
atendi uma paciente há algum tempo atrás
que mora em Dubai e eu fiz o atendimento
online E aí até mostrei para vocês no
grupo uma radiografia panorâmica dela e
vocês deram várias contribuições aí
significativas dos
achados e o chato foi que ela passou com
um profissional ali da dos Emirados
Árabes um dentista que falou olha
encontrei nada disso aí
que até mesmo você V no mundo inteiro
você tem prof
dentista como médico tem dentista que
não acredita nessa história de
cavitação de osteonecrose por aí vai né
por aí então essa é mais uma dificuldade
que nós temos aí né no é verdade é
verdade al e e com a kinesiologia médica
lain que eu acho interessante é que o
paciente acredita porque quando você faz
o teste ele percebe que ele perdeu a
força a perder a força significa que ali
não tem
eh uma condição favorável mas
ressaltando que kinesiologia não é bidor
né entende porque não Não tô criticando
o bidor mas para chegar diagnóstico é
muito vulnerável a falhas a kinesiologia
médica é um protocolo muito sério e
muito aprofundado de uma consulta onde
se avalia o ente em muitos aspectos não
se faz bidor não é kinesiologia que
muita gente pergunta Ah kinesiologia é
bidor não não é bidor não tem nada a ver
com bidor
né então tem que dar atenção à boca
também sabe alaim porque muitas vezes é
85% das causas das enfermidades em corpo
tem origem na boca e as os profissionais
e os pacientes pensam que é em
relacionado a canal né que é tratamento
ôntico que é relacionado a implante que
é relacionado a care Mas não é isso é
mais relacionado até a oclusão dentária
porque muda a postura que a todos esses
fatores porque também dente hígido dente
saudável pode ser um campo interferente
pode ser um dente neurológico entende
Alé e só só kinesiologia médica vai
descobrir isso enfim é um mundo para
falar Néia Cláudia estou lembrando agora
agora agora sto di un caso di
Alzheimer di una mossa che fa l'o di
faeo che vio vio ch Mia consulta e le
stava con metà differen in bocca stava
con amalgama
ouro non L ind che
implant titanio
e e con corren
corren m m m
al corren stava
conalis stava mensurando facendo la
somma con
vol boc vol Car
não sei
eh metal
diferente não consigo obgado Obrigado
Marcelo obgado P Obrigado obrigado muito
obrigado bem pessoal eu então acho que
eu vou já encerrar por causa que tá bem
tarde lá onde o Dr Fausto está dro está
Vampiro estou acostumado olí tranquilo
acostumado né se não dorme mais né Ness
Dorma que nem aquela ópera n Dorma
n nunca eu vou dormir não posso dormir é
né Tá certo que ninguém durma né É tá
certo mas enfim eu gostaria de agradecer
imensamente a participação desses dois
queridos especialistas Dra Cláudia Dr
Fausto
e informações bem valiosas que eu espero
que as pessoas possam depois acessar no
canal o vídeo gravado porque esse é o
tipo de Live que tem que ser re
assistida porque o conteúdo é denso o
conteúdo é rico Então você precisa
assistir duas três vezes para absorver
tudo esses conhecimentos aí e talvez em
futuras lives viu Cláudia eu tava
pensando aqui que que a gente pode fazer
até para tornar mais
fácil entendimento entendimento e as
pessoas poderem também eh ter uma
atração maior pelo pelo assunto né A
gente podia escolher um assunto
específico sim sim podemos eh que não é
kinesiologia em si e eh pegar esse
assunto e fazer um um uma ponte com a
kinesiologia como é que a kinesiologia
podemos eh ajuda nisso daí então por
exemplo vamos falar de um assunto que as
pessoas têm muito interesse por exemplo
Ah você que tem eh sintomas intestinais
tem constipa crônica é um exemplo
poderia ser qualquer outra doença e como
é que você usa a kinesiologia para a
atuar Nisso porque aí fica uma uma coisa
e um gancho para as pessoas terem mais
atração ótimo podemos podemos fazer uma
série até disso né
de de do que as pessoas precisam e e o
que podem Como podemos colaborar as
pessoas são muito imediatistas viu
Cláudia assim a gente a pessoa vai atrás
do do vídeo pelo assunto que é a dor
dela entendeu sim exato sei essa pessoa
no caso tem dor de estômago ela vai
assistir o vídeo do dor de estômago já
não vai ver o vídeo de dor de cabeça por
exemplo verdade eu sei disso dor crônica
Mas qualquer forma a gente tinha que
começar citando pras pessoas pelo menos
a kinesiologia médica e depois a gente
né Faz parte porque é é estranho o
assunto mas é isso podemos criar uma
série de necessidades E como você a a
Agora já faz parte do nosso grupo da
kinesiologia médica inclusive
interagindo com com você e vamos
ajudando pessoas a resolver o
diagnóstico através do conhecimento de
tudo que nós podemos passar para elas de
acordo com a necessidade
isso então novamente eu gostaria de
agradecer imensamente ao Dr Fausto
Bosque a Dra Cláudia Silveira foi um
prazer pela presença de vocês nós que
agradecemos e a gente realmente vai ter
essas outras oportunidades aí pessoal
muito obrigado por ter assistido
obrigada a to deixe seu coment obg por
todas e deixando seu comentário no vídeo
até
de propostas de futuras lives que a
gente possa est abordando assuntos
específicos com esse gancho da
kinesiologia nós estamos assuntos as
dúvidas por exemplo isso ass toda vez
que eu faço a Live com Dr Fausto me
sentindo culpado sabe vou dormir
com tril hor manhã lá na Itália e tal
então talvez talvez a gente faça a gente
faça uma uma live tranquila não fique
com semana no sábado mais cedo para ele
poder dormir mais cedo né Não Eu mesmo
não tem problema não tranquil estumar
alí Tranquilo então tá bom vamos vamos
criar uma série mesmo para poder ain até
surgiro a gente pode também tornar útil
a kinesiologia médica para a comunidade
para as pessoas que necessitam é isso
gnósticos boa ideia é então tá pessoal
Muito obrigado a todos vocês grande
beijo até a próxima OB Até beij tchau
gente ordens tchau beijo das da Itália
tchau tchau tchau